tene 72 when reigning world chess
champion Boris Spassky of the Soviet
Union met American challenger Bobby
Fischer in Iceland in Bobby Fischer goes
to war BBC journalist John Ida now
details the match and it's high stakes
geopolitical context the program's 45
minutes I would like to introduce
tonight's speaker who well leave it up
to your judgment as to which adjectives
he would like to apply the author of the
bestseller Vidkun Stan's poker and
tonight's book Bobby Fischer goes to war
John I'd now well Michael thank you for
that and thanks for inviting me to the
store to talk about our book I'm very
happy that you read Vikram Stein's poker
in two sittings I only wonder what took
you so long the HUD said I'd like to
start with Vic and Stein's poker as
you've mentioned it and perhaps just say
how that came about and then how we'd
managed to get in from writing about a
quarrel a sharp interchange between two
leading philosophers through a chess
match between two leading chess players
and how did David and I get to write
together at all
I used to present programs for the BBC
and in particular for the BBC World
Service and among the programs I present
it was one about British politics it was
a regular weekly roundup of British
politics called people and politics and
I presented it over the years and
producers came and went and I presented
the program um one of the producers who
came I was very happy to say and sorry
when he went one of the producers who
came as David Evans and we were riding a
train down to a seaside resort one
summer in the course of doing our
program together to one of the British
political party conferences and I did
what a lot of BBC people do to make
conversation I talked about something
I'd heard on the BBC that morning and
what I heard was a news report about the
Pope
visiting Ghana and the news report had
said that this was the first time a
reigning Pope had visited Ghana and I
said to David in my sub-editors way I
thought the word reigning was redundant
because there was no such thing as a non
reigning Pope it's an office held and
till death and we got into a
conversation about this around us were
these amazed delegates going to their
Party conference listening to this
conversation about reigning Pope in the
course of that I learnt that David had
studied vikram Stein at Oxford where he
was and so later I went there remains
that argument but later I saw some
correspondence about the incident at the
heart of Vikram Stein's poker this very
very sharp fierce interchange between
Ludwig Wittgenstein and Karl Popper
and the question whether Karl Popper had
lied in his autobiography about that
incident the book is a detective story
did he lie but I saw some correspondence
about it in The Times Literary
Supplement a leading British journal
literary journal weekly and I cut it out
and sent them I cut out the letters and
sent them to David to amuse him and out
of that came our book Vikram Stein's
poker which we were very happy surprised
and happy that it had the success it had
so the question then arose of another
book we had gone on writing the first
one together it feedin you know
was fun very demanding it's like having
a long conversation with somebody over
two and a half years that we wrote the
book this long conversation had gone on
extremely enjoyably and we had written
victims ties polka so what next
and that Daly was who still works the
BBC was doing a series on the World
Chess Championship and it contained a a
short reference quite short reference to
the 1972 World Chess Championship
between the American Bobby Fischer and
the Soviet world champion Boris Spassky
in Reykjavik the tiny capital of the
tiny state of Iceland stuck out there in
the North Atlantic and when he mentioned
it to me and we'd be discussing what we
might do next a bell rang this sounded
like something we ought to take a look
at the most notorious chess match of all
time we started with that and having
done the book and looked at other chess
matches we think that's still true over
30 years later this matched the most
notorious match chess match of all time
why was it so notorious so we moved from
a little incident perhaps 10 15-minute
incident in a small room in Cambridge
but sharp discussion between two
philosophers in front of about 30 people
we have moved from that to looking at a
world event played out in Reykjavik over
two months in front of the world's press
that make quite a change for us but
notorious why was it that this World
Chess Championship of all World Chess
Championships and after all that have
been going since 1886 why did this match
for the first time take the headlines
why did it share the front pages with
Vietnam with the dawning Watergate
affair in Britain it drove the ferocious
events of Northern Ireland in that
summer off the front pages for the first
time the BBC broadcast chess in New York
there's nearly o riots when a bar owner
wanted to switch to a World Series game
rather than carrier reports it made
stars of chess commentators they came
out of church halls and dark chess
club's up flights of wooden stairs to
become to become commentators and stars
in their own rights chess became the
rage it's what you talked about your
friends people who didn't know anything
about chess placed bets on the outcome
of the match why and where the
explanations given for it then were they
right when David and I writes we like to
get to where the action was our process
is really one of interrogating for past
obviously to interrogate eyewitnesses to
interrogate the documents but you like
to get along to the places themselves in
this case we went off and sat in the
hall in Reykjavik where the match was
played and talked the Icelanders who ran
it we went up to the great Keflavik US
Air Base and looked at where Bobby
Fischer went night after night to bow
and to eat American steaks and drink
American milk and feel happy that in
this one place he could be sure the
Soviets weren't getting at him sending
out electromagnetic Ray's to poison his
teeth
we went there we went to Moscow we sat
in a former village exclusively reserved
for writers and artists in the dead
winter silence of the Moscow woods we
sat and talked to boris spassky second
life Larisa about her relationship with
him about him about her view of the
match she went to Reykjavik and was
shocked by what she found when she got
there that the Boris who had set off for
the match so full of health was now
gaunt sleepless she thought he was being
got at a highly educated woman to this
day believes that someone somehow was
influencing her husband was it drugs
was it hypnosis was it parapsychology
that something was happening to him and
joy of joys we sat with the former
deputy minister of sport of the Soviet
Union viktor andreyevitch a Vernon and I
held in my hand what I think is a unique
document of this match his daily diary
of the events as sports minister he was
actually in charge of a team sport he
was a real communist apparatchik and I
may say like so many he's doing pretty
well today now the Soviet Union is over
he's deputy director of the Russian
National Lottery has a group tonight's
bigger office he has a Kai has a
chauffeur as bodyguard and he has the
diaries that he kept throughout his
ministerial life handwritten everything
that passed through his office he wrote
down at the time there could be no
better source of what the Soviets were
thinking and doing and saying to each
other
about bobby fisher' about the match
about their own world champion Boris
Spassky he wrote in anything that came
to hand the Diaries for this match are
actually written in a Soviet trade
ministry diary he must have picked up on
some visit so with all this
interrogating the past we stood back to
look at this match the most notorious
chess match of all time to ask about the
perception of it at the time and at the
time of course it was notorious because
first of all it was seen as a Cold War
match were back in 1972 a Cold War match
and Bobby Fischer did his best to make
sure that people saw it in that way he
undoubtedly saw himself in that way he
went to Reykjavik he said to teach those
lying hypocritical Russians a lesson and
he believed that just as in medieval
times national national leaders fought
it out hand to hand but he he was like
that he was going to Reykjavik to fight
it out with the Soviets hand to hand and
the press picked up this and they ran
with it
it's a very curious thing because of
course 1972 was the high point of date
hunt a new settlement was emerging
between east and west the skies were
filled with diplomats flying to
conferences to discuss strategic nuclear
weapons and what they called I remember
the phrase so a mutual and balanced
force reductions I didn't he ever got
anything on that but it was the high
point of day taunt leading journals on
international affairs declared the Cold
War over but not in Reykjavik in
Reykjavik Bobby Fischer had gone to do
her hand-to-hand battle so that was one
reason why it was notorious another of
course was the
personality of Fisher himself all those
adjectives that Michael read out was how
people saw him the novelist
Arthur Kessler coined a word for him he
called him a meme event where his own
life was concerned on his own affairs he
had all the sensitivity of a mimosa but
where other people were concerned he had
all the sensitivity of an elephant
trampling over them were the phrase
control-freak was not invented then but
it should have been to be invented for
bobby fisher' and his Thoth desire for
total control over all the circumstances
in which the match was held so we had to
look at that side of it and then of
course there was the Soviet side Boris
Spassky was seen as a perfectly
straightforward product of the mighty
Soviet chess machine you have to get
back into the mindset of the Soviet
Union where sports was of course
political the whole purpose of sport was
politics not the games themselves people
did sport because it made them better
communists better Soviet citizens it
produced concentration a sense of
strategies chess in particular it also
kept them away from drink in the evening
after a hard day on the collective farm
their natural tendency to go off and get
drunk if they are playing chess they
couldn't really do that so there was a
chess machine you might say that it
started just after the Revolution so you
could imagine that they were saying to
themselves
communism equals electricity plus chess
and chess was seen as exemplifying the
virtues of the Soviet Socialist system
and they had held the world title
uninterruptedly since 1948
and that was seen as showing that the
Soviet system worked the one of the
contenders for the World Championship
marked time on/off official rolled over
him six nil it was unparalleled he got a
real beating time on off from the Soviet
chess authorities he said there were
three things that demonstrated the
superiority of the Soviet system the
ballet the circus and chess so in Boris
Spassky went off to play in Reykjavik he
didn't go simply as a top gifted
world-class chess player defending of
the title he had quite justifiably won
in 1969 in the eyes of the Soviets he
went off to play for the Soviet Union to
exemplify the success of its system and
its virtues Soviet chess players were in
the phrase that they used expected to
play in red shirts but was this true of
Boris Spassky and the fact is nothing
could have been further from the truth
the London Times described him in the
match as the usual sort of benign Soviet
bureaucrat behind the scenes nobody saw
him like that behind the scenes he was
seen as well irritating is an
understatement or a major sort he was
not a Soviet patriot quite deliberately
not he was a Russian old-fashioned Slava
file Russian Patriot he would did not
believe in the system he didn't play for
the system he was his own man they found
it hard to decide quite what he was he
wasn't a dissident that was for sure but
was he an earless was he an artist was
he a joke their references in interviews
that were done for this book in which
they talk about him as though he were
that very traditional precise figure the
holy fool
so licensed gesture
able to say unpalatable things and have
them accepted because of the intense
religiosity but spastically defied the
system had he not been so gifted he
might have had a very different sort of
future indeed so we had to look at that
and of course we had to look at the
circumstances in which the match was
played Bobby Fischer's demand for total
control over the circumstances of the
match why the Soviets why Boris Spassky
didn't fight back on that he could have
quite easily have left break you Vic
with the title having declined to go
along with the demands made by Fischer
the Iceland leaders play their part in
it they're a tiny country they invested
a huge amount in the match they invested
so much they could not say no to Fischer
he played chicken with them and they won
and he won so all this comes in din into
the match itself the drain on Boris
Spassky is nerves and morale when
Fischer fails to turn up for the opening
of the match Boris is in Iceland his
preparation has not been good there's a
lot of worry about him back in Moscow he
hasn't worked hard enough he's played
too much tennis he hasn't taken a full
team with him that he really needed and
got a manager there he thought they'd be
cagey being he was probably right but
they might have helped him write the
steady drain on his morale on his
energies a Fischer does turn up loses
the first game on a blunder beginners
blunder Spassky isn't fooled by that
Fischer then forfeits the second game
will he stay there's a question would he
go now the question is will he stay he
stays on condition he plays in a small
back room Boris Spassky agrees he agrees
in one word he just says in Russian
that's fine push I'll stir okay and he
goes in and gets slaughtered
from then on it looks as though he will
be run over by Fisher as Fisher has run
over so many people before
steamroller his way to the title but
Spassky holds on he hangs in there
there's a remarkable series of seven
draws he can't get a breakthrough he
fights at the end everyone thinks that
Spassky is going to get sent to the
gulag in fact the word goes out he must
be treated in a civilized way he lives
to fight again
the paradox is it's Fischer who
disappears and forfeits his title the
Soviets think that Fischer would have
made a wonderful Soviet player you know
he's totally focused on chess nothing
else married him nothing else was there
for him to think about respess key would
made a wonderful Western player you know
it's full of jokes some wonderful mimic
he likes to get around with the boys
have a good time but it's Spassky who
comes back on fights again for the title
so it's very paradoxical you could say
what's this a cold war match not for the
world leaders certainly not for brioche
death the Soviet leader at the time not
for Nixon not for Henry Kissinger who
helped to get Fischer into the match it
was not for them a cold war match but in
cold war terms there's a paradox that it
was Spassky who has the character we
normally associate with the Western with
democracy individuality our kindness
towards others and it's Fisher who has
what we've always associated with the
Soviet bloc concerned only for himself a
total concern for himself and none with
others so this was indeed the most
notorious chess match of all time it's
also the most interesting and the most
paradoxical and it's all in here
I'm available for your questions when
you ask the question could you kind go
to the microphone yes absolutely
yes it's turned on great I heard that
after that match Bobby Fischer had the
highest rating anyone has ever had is
that true and has anyone ever gotten
that high again I think that's right and
nobody has ever got this the way in
which they work out these ratings but he
certainly had it at the time whether
he's hung on to it I don't know him
shame saying no but I can see a
colleague in the audience as he write
but he certainly had it at the time I'd
endure a man who obviously a chess
genius but he was also totally committed
to chess even Soviet grandmasters were
astonished at his commitment and it even
went so far that's a the final dinner
after the match or Fischer gets the
victors laurels you know and the first
thing is he goes up to get the check and
he opens the envelope and reads the
check several times to make sure the
figures are in the right order okay and
then puts in his pocket and goes and
sits down again no speech no dough
graceful word of thanks no
acknowledgment of his opponents and so
on and so forth but other people make
speeches in the meantime Fischer moves
into a chair next to the exhausted Boris
Spassky pulls out a pocket chess set and
proposes to discuss with Spassky where
he went wrong in the last game and Don
Shultz their former chairman our
President of the United States Chess
Federation told us about having dinner
with with official but you have
conversation I've dinner look round a
Fisher a bit playing on his pocket set I
said the only thing wrong problem with
Fischer in chess was the necessity of
having an opponent you know who played
these guys I'm sorry I'm sorry
does that answer your question Fischer
is still alive
at least he's thought to be still alive
and he gives evidence of being alive in
interviews he
gives to a Philippines radio station I
don't recommend anyone to listen to them
they are long long anti-american
anti-semitic rants he's not been seen
for some time after the matches you know
he didn't defend the title in the end
and it was taken away from him in 1975
he only played once more in public after
the World Chess Championship and that
was a rematch which was done for five
million dollars put up by yourself
businessman and has played in a couple
of places in Yugoslavia at that time the
United States was operating a cultural
embargo against Yugoslavia it's during
the civil war as part of United Nations
sanctions and as a result of playing in
that match Bobby Fischer came under
indictment here in the United States and
that indictment still stands he can't
return but nobody's seen him we chased
him through cyberspace we got an email
address for him we sent him some emails
proposing an interview we think he's in
Japan as I say and back came a whole
series of replies extraordinarily polite
and formal replies presumably from his
intermediary and then we had one which
was different I looked at Dave Dave look
to me we said that's Fischer it was a
very direct about the conditions for the
interview and so we did our best to the
lighting behind the table but we then
the next step was just another very
formal reply again saying mr. Fischer
will not give you an interview boris
spassky across lives in Paris and he's
accessible is not easy to pin down
because he's a Russian and he's always
going to decide tomorrow what he's going
to do but he did talk to us and it's a
man of great charm and still playing a
certain amount of chance
yes Boris Bobby Fischer was 29 though
curiously all the people who worked with
him referred to him as a kid I thought
it's very significant that he had New
York lawyers looking after his affairs
and they talked about him as a kid he
was only a kid he was 29 after all and
Boris Spassky was 35 so how old was I'm
sorry issue didn't make the journey to
the microphone and I forgot to ask your
apologies to our colleagues yeah
how old was Boris Spassky at the time of
the match he was born in 1937 I had a
very hard time just after the Second
World War
what caused him to go he said Vietnam my
belief is where is currently or he was
residing sorry where was he resigning he
said Vietnam or something in Japan in
Japan he's thought to be in Japan
nobody's actually seen him I don't think
for some time he's thought to be in
Japan
nah he's six feet - and you would think
he would literally stand out in Japan
but no one's actually seen him they're
always these rumors he's busy playing on
the internet but I think that's thought
not to be the case there's people taking
up his style he says he will only pay
what is called random chess from now on
what made him change he went from like
anti-soviet to like anti-american that
guy I couldn't read that into his
psychology he was very anti Soviet from
quite an early stage in his political
career in his chess career and that
steadily got worse he was also
anti-semitic from quite an early age and
thatis got worse but why he's taken
against your country the country huh I
do not know but he certainly has and I
think I was told that his foot pictures
now being taken down from the US chess
Hall of Fame as a result of the remarks
he made after nine
Bobby Fischer has been known to cut off
long term relationships with any friends
who were willing to talk about him to
the press did you therefore find it
difficult to find and any friends of his
a were willing to talk to you about
Bobby Fischer no we didn't have a
problem one or two called off interviews
with us because they are intending to
write their memoirs and they thought
their reminiscences should be full of
memoirs and not for our book but others
for instance Paul Marshall of his New
York lawyer very willingly gave us a
very complete interview on it
so and David Levy chess player who
stayed with Bobby Fischer
after the match when Fischer was living
in California he gave us an interview
they I think Robert Byrne gave us an
interview so we didn't have any problems
with that but we hadn't spoken to anyone
who is currently associated with Fischer
hey we don't know who the arm be we
don't know where he is she has talked to
Larry Evans who I think may have been s
yes no he wasn't a second but he was a
second in a previous match with with
Fischer and was stunned by the way in
which Fischer devoted to the young
Fischer devoted himself every hour of
the waking day to chess chess nothing
but chess
just like behind the microphone you can
get in there I just like to introduce
myself as one of the the the few people
who has actually met the guy I went to
high school with him
and actually played a game of chess with
him because this was we were both
freshmen he advised me to resign after
about two minutes but i reaiiy recall
him as a gangly kind of strange kid in
brown corduroy slacks and a t-shirt with
a kind of very distant spaced out look
on his face with three or four books in
Russian or German or whatever on chess
under his arm he flunked geometry twice
and he left high school after his
sophomore year because he wasn't given
leave to be able to go out and play in
the national championships and I don't
think he went back to school after that
a very strange person and I think
dismissive is another adjective that
hide head to your list well thanks and
the memory of family off by doing a
phone in this morning and a caller had
also been at Erasmus high at the same
time as Fischer he left as soon as he
was able he didn't see the point of
being there and I I have some sympathy
with him at this point because they he
is he's already a figure on the world
stage of chess a predicted future
champions he's the United States
Champion he'd been in the candidates
matches and that's his chess life and
then he has to go to school and share a
desk with somebody and be taught and you
think what an unbearable strain on his
personality that must have been at that
time how did he bridge the two worlds in
which in the one world he is seen as
this truly great player with all these
adults around him they're equal and
better and in this other world he's just
a school kid
yes absolutely I have two questions if
it's okay with you the first one
concerns I haven't had a chance to read
the book yet I just got it a couple days
ago from my birthday is there anything
new or previously very little reported
in the book that that you can just
quickly go over and the second one's a
little bit longer question so if you
want to answer that one first can i well
yes there's a lot new partly because
people are much freer to speak now but
the whole Soviet side is new nobody
before I mean a lot of the books have
written on the match and when I went to
interview the German referee he very
kindly and in a caring manner told me
there were already 421 books on the
match which is very nice of him to
reassure me in that way but I said I
think he meant it caringly but a lot of
them were in just after the match the
fact is that we have the Soviet side the
real Soviet side what they thought about
Boris Boris's preparation the stresses
and strains in Boris his team now he
quarreled with the two people he needed
most for his preparation what happened
to him how they felt about the course of
the match itself what was being said in
Moscow about it all white amor has not
been seen before and nobody before has
had access to this daily diary by the
deputy minister of sport who was in
charge of chess but again the chess
players in the Soviet Union now in
Russia felt much easier about talking
about it and for instance we had details
of the KGB involvement in the match
which had never seen the light of day
before and of course we have a lot about
Fischer because people felt much freer
to speak and also because the FBI file
on his mother has been released
the FBI followed his mother for 30 years
they thought she was a communist
sympathizer and possibly a Soviet spy
and the files extraordinarily detailed
you can correct some details of what
about Fisher's life in there
but also get their view of him and their
insights for instance there's a lot that
comes out of the file that he's knew
about his first visit when he was a
teenager to Moscow and one of the
reasons perhaps why he took against the
Soviets from their age anyway you've had
a second question and it's for those of
us who played chess for a wild
concerning the filming rights of the
seventy two match between a American
named Chester Fox and the organizers of
the tournament first game of course was
filmed and televised in the US and then
dispute came out afterwards and
literally all hell broke loose that was
one of the big reasons why the second
second game was forfeited in a book that
was written back 1974-75 the author who
was a life magazine reporter Brad darish
had written about the filming of it
ABC's Wide World of Sports bought the
rights and there was one game filmed
after that but apparently Fox had an
agreement with the engineer of the match
because all the games were then shown
closed-circuit afterwards and reportedly
there is a complete video copy of the
entire match in a bank vault in Iceland
Fox went back after the match and the
engineer said pay your bills and he said
no and he never got the film I wonder if
you had found any rumor or any further
information about this because as you
know it was dying everyone in the West
was dying to see this match live and or
on film and they basically got nothing
so I was wondering if you had found any
new evidence in your research about the
film's its it is indeed in here and the
Icelanders de gauche eiated with a
relatively inexperienced and
almost completely unknown in the in the
film industry at large New Yorker
Chester Fox that he had the film rights
the background to that agreement is it
slightly mysterious because it emerged
that Fox's name came up from Fisher's
advisory team and the Iceland are
certainly suspected or suspect today
that the agreement was not quite as
straightforward as they have been led to
believe but as you said though Fisher
took against the filming because he
claimed that you could the film the
noise of the film cameras was disturbing
him that noise was measured with a
state-of-the-art audio meter by an
Icelandic engineer and he said it was
totally outside the range of human
hearing that Fisher could not possibly
have heard it but Fisher took against it
and that created the original forfeit
and the problem was over match three
that move into the small room Fox was
undoubtedly given the runaround
he had this agreement with the
Icelanders but they did not stand up
they could not stand up to Fisher Fox
threatened to sue it was all smoothed
over here was obviously no point as you
say
other television organizations came in
and they tried to do they thought they
could get an agreement the Fisher but he
in the end you couldn't get that
agreement the closed-circuit he didn't
have the rights to and had no agreement
with the Icelandic engineers who set it
up he claimed that he ought to but
because it was purely for closed-circuit
use inside the hall he didn't have a
claim and every night the engineer
responsible for the closed-circuit
climbed across the roof of the hall to
get the tape of the closed circuit and
to spirit it out of the hall just in
case someone else
Chester Fox got their hands
that those tapes they're terrible
quality if you look people still
photographs from them those tapes are
somewhere but no one in Iceland is
prepared to admit that they know even
about the existence of the tapes let
alone where they are but there's a
treasure trove there for someone get to
Ricky quick question why did Spassky
choose to stay in Iceland after
everything decided to break break loose
why not just go home he decided to stay
in Iceland it's commonly thought
incidentally the Soviet authorities rang
him up and told him to leave and he
defied them it's not true that is
certainly not true they were in no
position to tell him to do but he stayed
because of what the frame of mind in
which he went he went for a celebration
of chess in the Russian phrase he went
for a feast of chess and that's what he
thought it was going to be he was of
great admirer of Fischer and liked him
he played him five times before one
three and drawn to
he was totally confident he could win at
the board his preparation there's no
question his preparation was was flawed
he was in charge of his own preparation
and it was not up to it he went with a
quite a difficult team as well but
nonetheless he went for the celebration
of chess and he stayed because he wanted
that and he thought he could win and
that's why he stayed
Fisher calls went to to declare war so
you have this imbalance right away
there is Boris Spassky looking forward
to a feast of chess and there is Bobby
and he's come to declare war well I'm
probably one of the few people here that
has met both of them I'm a chess player
myself I played in the same tournament
with spasticated in 1986 and I met
Fischer in 1964 I think one thing I
wanted to add that Spassky had a certain
amount of courage it's a little story
about him he gave a big talk and Russia
that B's huge meetings so they give
talks about chess and he was asked a
question why Paul Kerry's never became
world champion out to explain who Paul
Kerris was from Estonia and to give an
idea of his significance in chess they
used to have an elimination terms decide
who would challenge for World
Championship match and Kerry's finished
second in that tournament four times and
and then answer this question Spassky
said in public carries like his country
has not been blessed by fate and to say
that in the old Soviet Union took a lot
of courage I was wondering if you had
that sort of thing about the you come
across that sort of things when you
talked about Spassky the other thing I
would also also want to mention is an
answer to previous question there hat
Kasparov has surpassed Fischer's highest
rating however Kasparov himself actually
provided us put that in a blow to
context by pointing out that Fischer was
further ahead of his contemporaries than
anyone ever has and just like people say
they're people who have since become the
youngest Grand Master since Fischer
became younger than Fischer did but
Fischer didn't just become the youngest
Grandmaster he became a candidate for
the World Championship with 15 and no
one has ever done that he was
extraordinarily gifted I don't know if
it took courage on the part of Boris
Spassky to make that remark that Estonia
had not had a happy fate incidentally he
went to poor kerasys funeral
wearing a bright red suit taken by
Soviet chess players to indicate his
frivolous state of mind he made that
address yes there is a record of it in a
town in Kazakhstan called Shakti where
he addressed the locomotive chess club
and he said a number of things in that
address for instance he said if he had
not been a chess player he would have
been a priest he also said he thought
the Soviet chess players were extremely
badly paid and he instant's that he
would go and play in Santa Monica and
win $5,000 but if he played in for the
Soviet Union you have got about 500
rubles for it it's not quite the exact
figures but something like that the
local party secretary wrote to the
Central Committee to the Department of
agitation and propaganda complaining
about space his speech and reporting
that the audience's lovely old Soviet
language the audience had expressed
anger and bewilderment at what the world
champion had said but what were the
Soviet authorities to do about it he is
extraordinarily gifted player he was at
the top of the tree they were prepared
to go along with him to some extent to
say well he's irritating he's foolish
she's a free spirit he's a holy fool had
he not been so gifted they might have
taken a much more sinister approach
because these were not the only sort of
times he made those sorts of remarks he
was a Russian nationalist a Slava file
of a rare old-fashioned sort almost a
destroyer scheme figure a figure in that
his personality never really finished
but he was a joker
he was wonderful mimic he loved being in
company
the Saudis really didn't know what to do
about him I think but it's very
interesting that he everyone thought
he's got really going to get punished
after the match and it did they did make
a very severe comment on him which is in
the records and that I hadn't read for
the book let me just read what was said
about him in the post-mortem on the
match at the end of the post-mortem the
Soviet deputy minister of sport has
chaired the post-mortem which spassky's
ready people have really gone for him
makes this summing up he says all his
requests and wishes were fulfilled today
we can only regret that these
possibilities were not exploited in
fallen to the end spassky's words that
the match was a holiday and that they
must be an honest fight can be called
idealism this was not a holiday but a
fierce struggle and it is no coincidence
that Paul Marshall Fisher's lawyer said
that victory for Fisher was a question
of national and personal pride
unfortunately comrade Spassky did not
make such declarations but the word had
gone out from the Central Committee that
he was to be treated in a civilized
manner and he had a nine-month ban from
travelling abroad he lived to fight
another day and and you will know other
chess players and the audience will know
that he survived to get back into the
candidates round of the World Chess
Championship and indeed he got a lot of
support from the Soviet Union when he
played the true distant and defector
Viktor Korchnoi in a World Chess
Championship match and pass pass key at
that point was living in Paris but he
still got a lot of support from the
Soviets so it's a very mixed picture but
had he been a writer there's no question
that he would have been offered a
compulsory psychiatric help or may be
sent to will frozen dung out in Siberia
actually stepping to be the bad guy now
I'd like John I'd now is author of Bobby
Fischer goes to war it's published by
echo an imprint of HarperCollins on the
web at